I think we're gonna get started here I'm
Maurice Samuels professor in the French
department and the director of the Yale
program for the study of anti-semitism
and it's my great honor to welcome you
all here today what does it mean when a
mob carrying tiki torches chants Jews
will not replace us what does it mean
when they chant this at a rally in
defense of a Confederate War Memorial
this is a conference about racism
anti-semitism and the radical right it's
about what makes these different forms
of hatred unique and it's about the
complicated ways they intertwine in the
ideology of far-right
white nationalists today this is also a
conference about the similarities and
differences between the American
far-right and forms of racist populism
that have spread across the globe in
recent years
what does defending a statue of Robert
Ely have to do with elections in France
or with brexit
what does hostility to Muslims in
Germany have to do with a wall on the
border with Mexico these are just some
of the questions that this conference
will ask when Steve pitty and I began
planning the conference about nine
months ago we were aware that racism and
anti-semitism were on the rise both in
the US and across the world and we
wanted to learn more about it but we had
no idea just how urgent this desire
would become in the months since the
call for papers went out we've received
a lot of support from friends and
colleagues across the university and
across the world we have also received a
few more critical responses pointing out
that the right is not all racist and
anti-semitic and asking why we are
focusing on the right when everyone
knows the left is racist in anti-semitic
as well no doubt but I realized that in
the six years since I've been running
the ant
semitism program I had never hosted a
single speaker on the current far-right
it struck me as about time and let me
also say that we are well aware of and
grateful for the politicians across the
political spectrum left and right who
raised their voices to condemn
Charlottesville and who remain vigilant
in the fight against racism in
anti-semitism this is the fifth annual
conference of our our the international
consortium for research on anti-semitism
and racism it also represents the first
collaboration between the Yale program
for the study of anti-semitism and the
Yale Center for the Study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
directed by Steve pity it has been a
great pleasure to work with Steve and
his wonderful staff especially Aaron
Johnson whose organizational skills are
beyond compare before we begin with our
program I have a few quick housekeeping
announcements there's no eating or
drinking allowed inside this auditorium
emergency exits are located throughout
the hall Stage Left
and the doors you use to enter the hall
so please take a few moments to locate
the exit that is closest to you please
this is important please silence your
mobile phones right now and any
recording devices during each of these
sessions audio recording video recording
and photography are not allowed we are
going to be videotaping this conference
though any members of the media if
you're here have to check in with a
representative of the Yale Office of
Public Affairs if you've already not
done so and you can find them outside in
the lobby restrooms are located on the
first floor and in the basement please
contact a staff member outside if you
have a problem finding them and finally
if you need to leave the hall and have a
small bag or purse with you please take
it and remember that it needs to be
checked again upon re-entering the
auditorium so my thanks go
to our generous supporters for this
conference the Knapp Family Foundation
in the Edward J and Dorothy Clark Kemp
Memorial Fund I also want to thank Gary
Tomlinson the director of the Whitney
Humanities Center for agreeing to
co-host this conference and to the
wonderful staff of the Whitney
especially Marc Bouwer and an SOS Cove
the dedicated administrator of the
anti-semitism program for their tireless
help in putting this conference together
finally let me thank our distinguished
speakers who have come from across the
United States and from Poland Austria
Israel England and Germany to share
their knowledge with you thank you
thanks Maury I'm Steve pitty professor
of history and American Studies and
ethnicity race and migration and the
director as Maury said of the Yale
Center for the Study of race indigeneity
and transnational migration I want to
reiterate Maurice thanks to our generous
supporters to Gary Tomlinson and Mark
Bauer and an SLS gova and others here at
the Whitney Humanities Center to our
associate director Erin Johnson and our
senior administrative assistant Nandi
Cummings and others around the
university who helped make this
conference a possibility we received an
outpouring of support from various
academic departments and other units for
which we are grateful and I also want to
thank individual Yale faculty colleagues
who are contributing to this conference
today and tomorrow especially our panel
chairs
Matthew Frye Jacobson Martha Marcy Shore
Nancy Khalil Adam Stern Carol and Dean
Katie Lofton and Daniel Martinez Jose on
behalf of those colleagues and others
and knowing that we'll be talking about
important but sensitive topics I'd like
also to remind everyone here about Yale
University's policies on free expect
expression as everyone knows I hope Yale
strongly believes in the right of
individuals to express their opinions
but disruption of a university events
not is not consistent with the
university policies on free expression
so I would ask that each person here
respect to the right
of our speakers to be heard if a
disruption does occur during the
conference today or tomorrow Morrie or I
or some other University official will
ask for an end to that disruptive
activity if the activity doesn't cease
within a reasonable period of time will
repeat the request and we might have to
call upon university police to remove
audience members for disrupting the
event so we just asked that everyone
here present please respect and keep in
mind the university policy and now I'm
very very pleased very honored to
introduce to all of you Tamar Gendler
the Dean of the Faculty of Arts and
Sciences here at Yale Dean Gendler is
also the Vincent J skully professor of
philosophy and a professor of psychology
and cognitive science team Gendler
oversees the 53 departments and programs
that fall within the divisions of
humanities Social Sciences biological
and physical science and engineering and
applied science as a philosopher and a
cognitive scientist her academic work
brings together the techniques of
traditional anglo-american philosophy
with empirical work from psychology and
other social sciences her interests
include the relation between imagination
and belief the contrast between rational
and non rational persuasion and the role
of habits in shaping behavior and
judgment
Dean Gendler has held fellowships from
the andrew mellon foundation fellowship
program in the humanities the National
Science Foundation the American Council
of learned societies ryskamp fellowship
program the Collegium Budapest Institute
for Advanced Studies and the Mellon New
Directions program in 2013 Dean Gendler
was awarded the Yale College Sidney Mis
kiman Klaus 1975 prize for excellence in
teaching in the humanities please join
me in welcoming Dean of Faculty of Arts
and Sciences Tamar Gendler
thank you Steve Thank You Maury thanks
to all of you for joining us here these
feel like apocalyptic days there are
earthquakes there are wildfires there
are hurricanes and in addition
politically in the United States in
Europe in the Middle East in Asia
throughout the world these are times
that feel unsettled at moments like this
it is an opportunity for the Academy to
come together with those from outside
the Academy and to think about the ways
in which the echoes of the past the
echoes of language from earlier eras and
the creation of new modes of
conversation are subject to illumination
through the work which we do here in the
university we need to ask ourselves
questions like what can be known what
can be said what can be understood can
everything be illuminated perhaps to
coin a phrase we might ask ourselves
what is to be done at times like this we
need to remind ourselves as Hannah
Arendt
eloquently wrote that factuality itself
depends for its continued existence upon
the existence of a non totalitarian
world what does it mean to speak about a
non totalitarian world in that sense it
means to speak about an environment to
speak about a climate to speak about a
way of thinking about things that
overcomes the contingency of the
here-and-now and each of the disciplines
that is represented by those who are
present on our program disciplines like
history and political science philosophy
sociology anthropology economics and
importantly their intersections and
interspecies is dedicated to overcoming
the accident' allottee of the world as
it presents itself to us on its surface
each of these disciplines looks beneath
the surface of the rhetoric beyond the
symbol to try to understand the reality
the facticity the objectivity that lies
behind it to do this requires the
insights of multiple disciplines it is
no accident that this conference is
co-sponsored by the Yale Divinity School
the office of the Dean of Yale Law
School the Macmillan Center and its
counsels on African Studies European
studies Middle Eastern Studies the
department of African American Studies
the department of American Studies the
department's of French history Italian
Judaic Studies religious studies Slavic
Languages and literature's sociology
spanish and portuguese the Gilder
Lehrman Center for the Study of slavery
resistance and abolition the Gruber
fellowships and global justice and
women's rights and the justice
collaboratory of the law school it is no
accident that it brings together
scholars from the u.s. from Austria from
Israel from Poland from England from
Germany from academic institutions and
from research institutes and from
centers the urgency of the questions
that are addressed at this conference or
the reason that it is at moments like
this an honor and a privilege to have a
university like Yale with the resources
that have been dedicated to it to
explore from the perspectives of the
disciplines represented here
what sorts of responses can be given in
moments like these it is truly an
opportunity for as the panel we are
about to hear from border crossings
truly an opportunity to speak truly an
opportunity to listen and I'm grateful
to all of you and the conference
organizers for giving us the opportunity
to assemble this group here at this
place at this time at this moment thank
you Thank You Dean Gendler thank you so
much for your presence we now out like
to ask members of our first panel to
come up so we can begin that session I
do have to make the announcement that we
have the unfortunate news that panelist
Geoff Ely had to cancel his trip to New
Haven at the very last moment so he's
not present today for this first panel
but he did send all the sent along his
paper and I will be the one to read it
aloud to you though I hope you will not
ask me questions about the substance of
his paper if the first panel to come
forward
good morning everyone
I'm Matthew Jacobson I'm the current
chair of the ethnicity race and
migration program here at you know it's
great to see you all here this morning
and it's important that you are here
this morning I think how timely and how
urgent this conference turned out to be
is both saddening and maddening for
those of you who are visiting Trump's
America from other countries I'm so
sorry
but I'm also grateful for this chance to
think along with you about the pressing
and urgent problems that we were facing
here in the United States and so many
places around around the world let me
briefly introduce our panelists anton
chekhov Sauve is a visiting fellow with
the Institute for human sciences in
Austria
he's a research associate at the
Institute for euro-atlantic Cooperation
in Ukraine he is editor of the book the
book series explorations of the
far-right
and he is a member of the Editorial
Board of the open access a journal
fascism a journal of comparative fascist
studies his research and writing have
focused on the radical right-wing
parties in contemporary Europe on the
liberal tendencies in Europe the Russian
new right varieties of interwar European
fascism and right-wing cultural forms
such as music second Dan Hummel received
his PhD in history from University of
Wisconsin at Madison in 2016 and he is
currently a kingdom fellow at the
Institute for research in the humanities
therein in Madison last year he was a
postdoctoral fellow in history and
public policy at the Harvard Kennedy
School he's published in forums
including religion and American culture
religions religion and politics and war
on the rocks and he is currently
finishing a manuscript with the
University of Pennsylvania press titled
a covenant
of the mind American evangelicals Israel
and the construction of a special
relationship and then finally as as
Steve pity mentioned Jesse Lee will not
be here but Steve pity will be reading
his paper and Steve pity is literally
the man who needs no introduction
[Music]
good morning everyone my name is anton
chekhov sulfur's I was nicely presented
and I'll be talking to you about the
relations between Russia and the Western
far right or far right in the West the
paper is called the far-right front of
the Russian active measures in the West
I'll explain these if they had not known
to you these some of these terms a bit
later but I will start with the with
there's some one historical reference
this historical reference is coming back
more than ten years ago after the
invasion of Iraq and the beginning of
the note is a very interesting document
was found in the former foreign ministry
of Iraq and the document was an
agreement between two officials or two
members of the Austrian far-right party
the Freedom Party of Austria and the
regime of Saddam Hussein and that
particular document was about lobbying
efforts on the part of the Austrian
Freedom Party they would lobby in Europe
for the for the lifting of the sanctions
that were imposed on on on on Hussein's
Iraq and one of the signatories of these
documents average toddler the evos tree
and far-right politician and who
received 3.5 million dollars for that
effort he was a minor minor function or
a functionary of that particular party
but but in so more than ten years left
after that and during this so-called
referendum in Crimea that was followed
by the annexation of this Ukrainian
region by the Russian Federation average
toddler the same guy who signed an
agreement with Hussein's regime he was
one of the observers of this so-called
referee
so when we are talking today about how
Russian actors various Russian actors
cooperate with the far-right in the West
that's actually a very long story
it didn't happen last year did not
happen first with the multi-million loan
that the French a far-right National
Front received from one of the Russian
banks it studied much much earlier and
about talking to you about two
particular areas which I find most
interesting areas of cooperation between
these two entities on the one side you
have its various Russian actors and
stake holders and on the other side you
have far-right parties and far-right
activists in the West but before I do
that I will try to explain very briefly
some of the terms that I used in my in
the title of my paper and that is first
the front organization of the front
organization is a term that is coming
from the Cold War era and this means an
organization or a group of individuals
in operating in the West and during the
Cold War that was the west of Western
Europe and the US and Canada front
organization would be a group of
individuals who would be engaged in
activities that would be beneficial to
the Soviet Union and that particular
organization front organization that
would be it would be consistent
Westerners not the Soviet people not not
not the agents but individuals with
Western passports too so to say but they
would be sponsored by the Soviet Union
and the active measures is a is a term
that was devised elaborated by the by
the KGB by the security services of the
Soviet Union and that would be
activities aimed at disrupting
democratic processes in the West that
would be about this information or
misinformation propaganda etc etc why
I'm using this terms because I see the
continuity between the Cold War era and
the world that we are living today I
mentioned that average toddler the
signatory of the agreement with Hussein
he was an electoral observer the
so-called referendum in Crimea in 2014
in March 2014 but engage the Russian
organizations various Russia the Russian
organization started to engage with the
far rights activist for this particular
reason to observe elections at around
2004-2005 if you may remember 2003 2005
that was the period of so-called color
revolutions in the post-soviet space
first that was Georgia with the
revolution of roses and came Ukraine
with the orange revolution 2004 and then
Kyrgyzstan in 2005 and the Russian
regime was quite scared with of these
color revolutions the the the fear was
that the US and the West in general is
engaged in the war against Russia and
against Putin because big because before
that Putin quite enjoyed the honeymoon
with the West during his first
presidential term 2000 now the years
2000 2004 but those color revolutions
made him think that the West was trying
to overthrow put into regime and looking
at how people were mobilized against the
stolen elections because all these three
so-called revolutions I would not call
them revolutions they were quite
successful protests against the
electoral fraud so the Putin's regime
was looking at how people who were
mobilized and if they saw that they were
mobilized by in part at least partly by
the electoral monitoring organizations
such as the OCE such as the extra
monitoring mission of the European Union
and some other established institutions
he would say that those elections are
not fair they're not
were not open and essentially they were
unfair so we couldn't really accept that
that particular person was indeed
elected and given these importance are
all the significance of these electoral
electoral monitoring missions some
Russian actors decided to create their
own electoral monitoring missions to
challenge the results of monitoring of
all the European and Western
organizations in general and so they
started creating several organizations
and they of course they had a problem
the problem was that if they would if
they brought monitors from the
post-soviet space that would not be
really that would be not a very
Authority position if they said for
example that so when a pro-russian
president or progression party was
elected and won the elections unfairly
and if those people monitors coming from
again from from Russia or even from
Ukraine and Moldova from the purpose of
your space if they were said that that
they weren't fair nobody would really
believe them so they decided to engage
with the Western politicians members of
parliament members of the European
Parliament and the problem was that very
few people in the West would participate
in the show working essentially to the
benefit of Kremlin's foreign policy and
they but they understood that they could
actually engage with far-right
politicians and the first organizations
that Western organizations that started
working with the Russians was Poland
based center for geopolitical analysis
headed by Matteo skorsky neo-nazi former
neo-nazi activist and by that time of
just a radical right-wing populist and
the Belgium based organization Eurasian
Observatory for democracy and elections
headed by neo
just activists Luke Michelle and these
people using their far-right networks in
the West especially in the European
Union started to invite all those people
their friends their colleagues to go to
referenda and those were friend that
would be sometimes just a legitimate or
illegal or they would be going to
various elections and essentially they
would always they would always
corroborate or confirm the interests of
the Russian Federation in any particular
country they would go to the states
which well not the States but the
territories that consider them States
but not consider states such as say
Transnistria separatist area in Moldova
or South Ossetia or hacia territories
that belonged to Georgia but but
occupied by by the Russian forces so
when and that was starting in 2005-2006
so when we saw them again these monitors
in in Crimean March 2014 that was just
the tip of the iceberg because that
business developed very actively 10 B
with 10 years before that it's many
people during in the course of years
many people participated in of those
fake electoral monitoring missions for
example Nick Griffin from the fascist
British National Party a lot of people
from the National Front from small
organizations in France far-right
extreme right organizations and they
would again always confirm the Russian
point of view on particular elections
also in the course of time these far
rights activists they started to
take part in another effort that would
be pro-kremlin that would be to the
benefits of Moscow's state propaganda
and one of those areas and just to just
to shortly come back to these electoral
monitoring missions that was the edge
that was essentially the first
institutionalized form of cooperation
between Russian actors and the far-right
and the West just the the very first
form and the the second area another
institutionalized form of cooperation is
in the media and again brief historical
reference 2008 all this 2008 Russia
provoked Georgia into a war that lasted
only for five days it ended with the
occupation of South Ossetia and Abkhazia
again the war lasted only for five days
and the Russians want easily but there
was a feeling and if you read the media
friendly to the Kremlin friendly
friendly to put it in a prime minister
at that time and President Medvedev
experts and politicians and political
scientists in Russia would be loyal to
the Kremlin they would all say that
Russia won the war easily but it it lost
the information war in the West
basically they failed to they failed to
make the West believe that Russia had
legitimate reasons to occupy those
territories they realized that they they
just could not convince the West in in
that that the Russia's actions were
justified and at that time and they
started thinking about this so what can
be done
[Music]
yes they want they will easily but then
they also started to enhance their
military potential because they
understood that there were a lot of
mistakes with done with the military
planning and logistics but again what
what can be done about the information
war at that time they already had TV
station TV channel Russia today it was
still called Russia today at that time
it was launched in 2005 and at that time
Russia today was very was very different
from what it is now Russia today at that
time was just a TV channel that would
promote Russian culture and so it was
essentially a soft power tool of the
Russian Federation so they thought well
it doesn't really work it doesn't really
work to say that Russia is good so they
decided to change the agenda of Russia
today and some other international
outlets of media that they had at that
time for example the the radio station
the voice of Russia which operated since
the 90s and was available on the
Internet in several European languages
so in 2009 a year later they decided to
rearrange Russia today they dropped the
name Russia today they only are they
became just the artsy to conceal the
obvious Russian link of the TV station
and they changed also the approach so
Russia in their narrow it say Russia is
good word would remain but the but the
main narrative would be that the West is
bad so they would combine these two
narratives to promote the vision they
thought that Russia today is not really
working we would not be able to convince
the West that Russia is really good and
its actions are justified we would try
to influence the audience's in the West
that their own governments their liberal
democracy and their way of life is
actually bad is actually worse than what
they have in Russia and again the
problem is
who would be the ly commentators who
would be working for this Russian TV
station because that would that would be
there should be all those people should
be Westerners themselves and already in
2008 shortly after the russian-georgian
who in August that year there was a
conference again in Austria that was
dedicated to the to the war in August
and Heinz Christian Strava the leader of
the Freedom Party of Austria said
something about contemporary president
of Georgia Mikhail Saakashvili that he
said that he was a dictator and actually
Russia's actions were justified and the
Russian media realized that they have a
huge potential they have a resource they
have a pool of commentators could be
very good for artsy and those were far
rights activists those were conspiracy
theorists those were isolationists a
left-wing extremist but especially far
rights activists so they would invite
them to our tea and talk how how how the
multicultural West how the you how
Europe or the European Union are very
close to collapse our euro zone is not
working how immigration policies are not
working and cetera et cetera what is
interesting here is that Russia Putin's
Russia considers considers itself as a
anti-fascist state so they obviously had
again a problem how they present those
people and they decided to they they
come up they came up with a very easy
solution they would just not mention
that they were coming from the far right
so Richard Spencer who you may know one
of the anti heroes of Charlottesville
incident he would be talking in 2007 to
now 2012-2013 if I'm not mistaken he
would be called an expert on Syria and
he would be talking about the civil war
in Syria and presented as an expert of
whom probably he doesn't really know
much about Syria and the same the same
thing with all other people so the the
the RT host would not would not say that
I'm Eric shaprut a conspiracy theorist
from the National Front was the
conspiracy theory coming from the
far-right National Front he will be just
called the member of the European
Parliament over the French member of the
European Parliament so that was and it's
still going on still today in order to
discredit migration policies of the
European Union and to incite some social
discontent they were talking about the
developments in Britain after brexit
they would invite to comment on that
none other than the person from the
British National Front so you see their
approach they would try to decent form
Western publics to undermine liberal
democratic narratives or and basically
ruin the status quo and since only maybe
three left three minutes left for me
I'll just say that this these two areas
of cooperation between Russia and the
far-right became the first two
institutionalized formed forms of these
cooperation they started to develop
these activities and what is interesting
is that far rights activists themselves
because these these two areas the the
the initiative came from the Russian
Federation but in 2007 from 2011 or even
earlier far-right organizations in the
West in Italy that in Italy in France in
Bulgaria in in Belgium
in Hungary far-right effectively started
their own initiatives not being
supported from Russia from the very
beginning they presented sort of resume
for Putin's regime what they can do and
how they can contribute to what they
believe towards the agenda of the
Russian Federation would be happy to
answer some questions if they arise and
thank you good morning I want to start
just by restating the title of my talk
reconciliation or realpolitik the
alliance between the American and
Israeli right so I want to begin by
outlining that central question of the
title is the cooperation we see
increasingly between the American
largely Christian rights and the Israeli
right protect propelled finally by
reconciliation or realpolitik we might
restate the question is this
relationship built on mutual respect and
shared world view or on pragmatic cold
political calculations a third way is
this in the case of Philo Semitism or
anti-semitism the answer weighs heavily
on the themes of this conference to
openly state the end of my argument at
the beginning I'm claiming that the
evangelical establishment in the u.s.
especially the leaders and institutions
that we call Christian Zionists are not
anti-semitic at least not in the
traditional way we talk about
anti-semitism indeed a better
description may be Philo Semitism my
main qualifier with using the term Philo
Semitism is that it implies Jews are
passive recipients rather than active
partners in this relationship as I hope
to show this is far from the case with
this caveat in mind I'm going to argue
for a reconciliation interpretation that
highlights how the current generation of
Christian and Jewish right-wing
activists in the support Israel movement
have created a radically new
understanding of themselves and each
other this new understanding between
evangelicals and Israelis emphasizes
judeo-christian compatibility religious
solidarity and words they use covenant
Brotherhood the American Israeli right
had converged on a discourse of biblical
covenant to understand their shared
political goals they have certainly
practiced their fair amount of
realpolitik but underlying this is a set
of ideas and beliefs that give both
sides meaning and increasingly blurred a
boundaries between the Christian and
Israeli right I'm going to cover three
recent examples of American Israeli
right-wing cooperation the first is some
episode that happened in 2013 about
Texas A&M Peace University the second is
about the Feast of Tabernacles which is
a celebration in Israel every year
largest Christian Zionist gathering of
the annual gathering and the third is
the Christian version of birthright
Israel that has emerged since 2011 in
addition to making my arguments about
reconciliation these episodes can also
offer a type of rudimentary map of the
places in which the Christian and
Israeli right are engaging each other so
a first example of increasing
collaboration between the American
Israeli right offers us some familiar
names in the conservative Christian and
Jewish world in October 2013 Governor
Rick Perry now the Secretary of Energy
flew to Israel to announce a new Texas
A&M campus to be built in Nazareth named
Texas A&M Peace University the school
was to serve a largely arab-israeli
student population and be the first
foreign major foreign University in
Israel Perry credited part of this
initiative to Pastor John Hagee who
acted as the go-between for Texas A&M
Perry and Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu
Haidee is a Pentecostal mega church
pastor in San Antonio Texas and 2006 he
helped found or
he was the initiator of the largest
Christian Zionist lobby group in the
u.s. Christians United for Israel for
short kufi Kufa now has over three
million registered members thinking
about the small network of contacts
between Hagee and Perry and Netanyahu
it's quite remarkable to see how far up
the political ladder Christian Zionists
like Hagee have ascended in the last
decade since 2006 just in July of this
year
poof I hosted Mike Pence as keynote
speaker at their annual Washington DC
summit Hagee is a staunch supporter of
Trump though in recent weeks he has
warned the administration that it would
disappoint Kufa if the American Embassy
did not move to Jerusalem quote soon in
2013 Hagee was approached by Perry
because he was a longtime friend of
Netanyahu's dating back to the 1990s
during Netanyahu's first tenure as prime
minister then that not who made a
concerted effort to court the Christian
Right in the u.s. Peggy was famous at
that time for his annual night to honor
Israel events since the early eighties
which were in a religious gathering
celebrating Israel every year and Hagee
also hosted massive tour groups every
year to the Holy Land from his Church in
San Antonio peace University was pitched
as a gesture of peace and economic and
educational uplift Israel's underserved
Arab population this may not seem at
first past to be a logical outlet for
right-wing cooperation indeed the
strange fit might explain why two years
later in 2015 the plans were
dramatically scaled back but the project
served multiple and needs at the moment
in 2013 and illustrates how right-wing
cooperation advances both communities in
the US and Israel for Perry
in 2013 planning for his next
presidential bid in 2016
needing to look a little smarter if you
remember his gaffes in 2012 he was able
to lift his foreign policy credentials
and pro-israel bona fides which are
crucial to GOP primary voters Hagee
acted as a high-level messenger an
advisor to elite politicians in his home
state of Texas and Internet
what he calls his spiritual home of
Israel and finally Netanyahu was able to
strengthen his ties to rising
politicians like Perry and bring staunch
Christian Zionist supporters like Hagee
into more mainstream in this case
educational initiatives that improve
Israel's public image we might call
Texas A&M Peace University a an example
of realpolitik cooperation between the
American and Israeli right the fact that
this work was ostensibly meant to serve
the arab-israeli population made it hard
to criticize by skeptics as Hagee
explained these types of initiatives
help combat what he called international
anti-semitism by portraying Israel in a
positive light the right-wing
cooperation on display illustrates how
the polarization of both American and
Israeli politics has contributed to an
international network of American and
Israeli contacts these types of contexts
are essential to the success of
reconciliation and that brings me to my
second example getting closer to the
heart of this reconciliation of the
American Israeli right every year the
largest tourist event in Israel is the
Feast of Tabernacles held in Jerusalem a
Christian Zionist celebration held
during the Jewish holiday of Sukkot it's
hosted by the International Christian
embassy the largest Christian I designed
this organization in the world with
offices in more than 80 countries and
headquartered in Jerusalem the embassy
was formed in 1980 to express Christian
solidarity with the Jerusalem law passed
in the Knesset that year defining an
undivided Jerusalem at the eternal
capital of Israel the Christian embassy
found support from the Likud Party then
in power and has been far more friendly
with Likud prime ministers ever since in
the 80s the Christian embassy received a
lot of bad press for its roles in
supporting right-wing militias in Latin
America where a lot of its constituents
came from including the Contras
if there's something like a global
network of right-wing Christian
organizations the Christian Embassy is
certainly part of it the Feast of
Tabernacles is not only notable because
it is a powerful display of
and support for Israel it's also a venue
for Christians and Orthodox Jews to meet
in a non-christian majority setting
that's often crucial for the Jews their
meeting on sort of Jewish turf to
develop a common language to express
their shared concern for controversial
policies including settlement building
in the West Bank and so-called religious
freedom issues on the Temple Mount
each year the Feast features a number of
Israeli speakers who explain how
important Christian Zionist support is
to Israel one of the most influential
and skilful Jewish theorizes of
Christian and Jewish cooperation is
Rabbi [ __ ] Riskin who helped found the
West Bank settlement of that peratt's
which is just outside of Jerusalem
across the the Green Line and that's
where he still lives and in recent years
Riskin has founded a Center for Jewish
Christian understanding and cooperation
as he calls it Riskin is an Orthodox
rabbi born in New York City who
emigrated to Israel in 1983 with an
Orthodox circles he's actually known as
a liberal for his stance on orderin
ordaining women in as rabbis in terms of
Israeli politics however risking as a
hardliner
who believes the Messianic age is being
ushered in through Jewish settlements in
the West Bank rich kid is now regular
speaker at the Feast of Tabernacles he's
done at multiple years and he espouses
his concept of covenant Brotherhood that
sees Jews and Christians working
together to bring about the Messianic
age the Covenant in Riggins
understanding is chiefly between God and
the Jewish people as laid out in the
book of Genesis Christians to have a
role to play for Riskin as described in
Genesis 12:3 which is in part of the
narrative where God is talking to
Abraham and God says I will bless those
who bless you and to those who curse you
I will curse this verse comes as God is
explaining his covenant illallah Gatien
x' to Abraham Christian Zionists and
some Orthodox Jews like Riskin take this
as a commandment and covenant 'el
language that encompasses Jews and
Gentiles in God's plans for world
Redemption this is perhaps the most
crucial
a reference to understanding Christian
and Israeli right-wing cooperation this
new thinking works against the old way
that both Jews and Christians talked
about their relationship to God and each
other for most of Christian history the
church defined itself as the new Israel
as the inheritor of God's covenants and
blessings that were once bestowed upon
ancient Israel this so called
supersession theology has been
identified by scholars as one of the
chief engines of Christian anti Judaism
and a contributor to Mahdia
anti-semitism some theologians have gone
so far as to blame this theology as a
cause of the Holocaust in any case the
idea both from Christian and Jewish
leaders that the other tradition was
covenant ly out of sync with God has
held sway for much of the last 2,000
years but since the Holocaust there have
been many efforts on both the left and
the right to revise Christian
understandings of the relationship
between Christians Jews and God at the
same time a segment of Orthodox Jews
including Riskin have been doing the
same thing they have converged largely
in the cooperative relationship between
Christians and Jews and supporting the
Jewish settlement of the West Bank here
Christians have been encouraged by Jews
in their Philo semitism to see the
redemption of the world is working
through the Jewish people that Riskin is
the conveyor of these ideas he fits the
evangelical stereotype of a Jew nicely
he's religiously Orthodox he's in Israel
this only reinforces Christian attitudes
and their conviction that they're on to
something okay so getting to my third
example this final example illustrates
how the american israeli rights are
cooperating on combating with it they
identify as the most threatening strain
of what they see as the anti-semitism as
the primary force inhibiting this
covenant or relationship between
christians and jews and that is
left-wing anti-zionism on college
campuses most of us know about
birthright israel tours which has sent
thousands of jews between the ages of 18
and 26 on a ten-day tour of israel these
tours claimed to strengthen Jewish
identity in the Diaspora and create
create connections between
diaspora and Israel well Christian
evangelical Christians have created
their own versions and two recent
versions have emerged since 2011
covenant journey is the first one that
was founded by Matthew Staver Staver
leads the religious freedom group
Liberty Council and is a professor at
Liberty University whose Chancellor is
Jerry Falwell Jr covenant journey takes
groups of 40 to 50 Christian college
students to Israel - and this is in
their word strengthen their Christian
faith and equip them to be goodwill
ambassadors for Israel a more recent
venture called passages is funded by the
green family of Hobby Lobby fame and
performs a similar service though it's
group often the group's they're often
number in the hundreds it's safe to say
that given the leadership and funding
sources of both of these groups they are
squarely in America's Christian rights
one of the key contacts in Israel for
both groups has been Rivka Kidron an
advisor to Netanyahu and a consultant to
staplers liberty Counsel group the
emergence of Christian Student tours to
Israel points to the shared concern the
American and Israeli right have for
combating what they identify as the twin
and connected developments of rising
left-wing opposition to Israel most
identified with the boycott divestment
and sanction movement and declining
religious observance on American
campuses Jewish observers like Riskin
voiced their support for increased
Christian activism on college campuses
recognizing that he and other Jewish
settlers often have more in common with
conservative Protestants than anyone
else and how they view Israel's divine
calling other Christian Zionist groups
including CUFI have focused on the
campus as a crucial area of support for
Israel they have created chapters in
hundreds of universities around the u.s.
run by students and they've partnered
with Israel's foreign ministry to invite
speakers and planned events combating
the BDS movement or promoting the common
what they call judeo-christian values
that the US and Israel have in common
there is a rising fear among the
American Israeli
right that younger millennial generation
Christians do not hold the same fervency
of support for Israel or even interest
in the Middle East that earlier
generations did this is combined with a
concern that the BDS movement will gain
momentum and negatively impacted your
economy or negotiating position the
focus on the campus reveals part of the
right-wing nature of this relationship
between the American and Jewish right
both feel marginalized from American
higher education and yet see higher it
as a crucial space for forming lasting
attitudes towards Israel they
furthermore understand the battle for
public opinion and their covenant
illallah gation zazz deeply intertwined
from Peace University to covenant
journey to student to Kufa student
chapters the American Israeli right have
decided that university campuses are in
many cases the biggest threat to their
interests so with these three examples I
want to draw a couple or a few
conclusions first the range of American
and Israeli white-winged collaboration
is wide stretching from political
efforts to religious exchange to
alliances on what we would call cultural
work issues in on campuses right wing
cooperation in these areas was mostly
dormant before the 70s this Alliance is
relatively new and indicates changing
attitudes toward Israel but also an
evolving view of the inter-religious
relations between Jews and Christians
contrary to how many this is my second
conclusion contrary to how many
observers have characterized the
relationship the two most charged issues
that have led people to wonder if the
Christian Right has availed
anti-semitism are largely non-issues
when you get into the movement and that
is evangelical apocalyptic theology and
evangelical attempts to convert is ready
Jews these are mostly absent from the
rhetoric particularly you get into the
movement of people like Hagee virtually
all Christian Zionist leaders from Hege
on down have publicly declared that they
do not attempt to convert Jews and
they've actually taken flack from other
evangelicals for doing this in practice
there is very little effort or money
expended
converting Israelis to Christianity
similarly Heggie holds a lot of very
strange and x views that he's aired over
the years and books that have sold a lot
but he over the years has managed to
compartmentalize that part of his
Christianity and that entire discussion
to books and to Christian audiences he's
learned over time that that is not
something that Israelis want to really
hear about so even with these advances
sort of on the tactics does this
reconciliation amount to a declaration
that anti-semitism is gone from the
Christian right this is difficult to
answer and certainly if the answer is
not affirm no certainly the overt
anti-semitism of early and mid twentieth
scent of the mid twentieth century is
gone within evangelical circles is not
acceptable to traffic in traditional
anti-semitic tropes even anti Judaism is
on to the client in many seminaries as
evangelicals reinterpret Jesus's Jewish
background in their understanding of
what Judaism is on the other hand the
view of the ideal Jew that most
conservative Christians hold resembles
[ __ ] Riskin in this of course rich kin
and Christian Zionists agree this is a
byproduct of their shared worldview
dominated by left-right secular
religious categories it is in anti
secularism anti leftism and anti-muslim
sentiments that the American Israeli
right find common enemies and prejudices
the limitations of this Philo Semitism
of the rich skin type Jew came to the
fore in the wake of Charlottesville
where as we've already heard the white
supremacists were chanting Jews will not
replace us both evangelical leaders and
the Israeli government led by Netanyahu
were slow to respond or denounce these
events only after Trump's second
statement did that Yahoo tweet a
nondescript combination of anti-semitism
neo-nazism and racism without any
mention of who or what was the problem
undoubtedly the lukewarm condemnation by
both the Christian and Israeli right is
due to their dependency on Trump for
most there's an unavoidable realpolitik
calculation here but this example also
reveals the potential downsides to a
Philo semitism that Tirpitz Jews through
the
mental theology the further away from
Israel that anti-semitism appears the
more deaf the Christian right seems to
be because of the most recent
anti-semitism came from the alt-right
the left-right worldview schema that
these Christian Zionists hold failed to
make sense of the anti-semitism as
anything but an aberration both the
Christian and Israeli right seem to have
also interpreted white supremacists and
the counter protesters as equally
anti-semitic and equally worthy of
condemnation endorsing Trump's position
that both sides are to blame
Netanyahu's son for example who is very
active on social media condemned the
neo-nazis on Facebook but added that the
counter protesters quote hate my country
and America - in my view just as much
the same attitude expressed was at rest
by evangelicals for example Koufos
website linked to a Times of Israel
article that followed one of the
protesters with the white nationalists
who claimed that he himself was not a
white nationalist finally the impetus
behind this reconciliation is political
and theological which should not be
missed is a radical rethinking of the
relationship between Christians and Jews
that has settled on a covenant 'el
language defending judeo-christian
values with Israel and the US as the
pillars of Judaism and Christianity the
extent to which this type of Philo
Semitism pervades right in thinking
today is owed to the deep connections
that have been forged between the
American Israeli right and the
theological system they have constructed
together thanks
hi for those of you who came in I'm
reading Jeff Ealy's paper on his behalf
because he's not able to be here the
paper is entitled anxiety about borders
refugees migrants see and the radical
nationalist imaginary he begins in the
time allowed I'm gonna make a few very
general points focusing initially on
Germany then building to more general
European observations first I'm
constantly amazed even after all these
years by the ease with which people
reach viscerally for simple abstractions
of quote Germany or quote the Germans
when people in reacting to events over
there this is true of the ordinary
citizen the person in the pub or the bus
queue and so forth it's true of
journalism it's but punditry and the
blogosphere and it can also be true of
ourselves especially those who dwell in
the squalor scholarly world so I want to
say strongly here that there are no
Germans and that conflation Airy
singular sense there are only multiple
and diverse categories of people who
live inside the contemporary German
national state or choose in other ways
to affiliate there and these are
categories defined with and against each
other along all sorts of dimensions
including gender class work religion
sexuality sport music culture more
capacious lea region patriotism politics
and although there's still enormous
resistance to acknowledging this as an
operative category race this rather
elementary point about the need for
conscientious specificity becomes
central for our discussion on the one
hand given the this default
understanding we shouldn't really be
fazed by the existence alone of radical
right-wing politics per se
whether that politics sees itself
validly in those terms or whether it
resorts to obfuscation if a variety of
forms of societal conflict and
contention are endemic to life under
capitalism not least in it's more or
less Universal neoliberal versions than
we should expect some ugly expressions
of grievance and complaint to emerge in
the public sphere and to seek organized
expression all the more so given the
ease of rapid electronic communication
those expressions will grow all the more
vociferous with worryingly widening
residents in times of crisis and
oppressively inescapable ways since 2001
since 2003 since 2008 and since 2015 its
crisis that supplies the Register's
idioms and grammars of our everydayness
in other words we should most definitely
take the rise of mijita and after you
seriously but we shouldn't get too
apocalyptic too quickly about their
ability to register electoral success
and we certainly shouldn't see this as a
recruit recrudescence of older forms of
radical right-wing politics from the
earlier 20th century in fact even in the
most successful of democracies and even
at the most stable of times there will
always be malcontents who oppose or
disrespect the always shifting bases
which democracy for from which democracy
is formed so in that case the key
question rather key questions rather
become first how stable or unstable how
contradictory how coherent is the
socio-political coalescence that these
movements represent second how can they
most effectively be opposed and third
perhaps most vital of all how resilient
are the given institutional resources of
democracy in the polity and in the state
in a similar vein we should take
incredibly seriously
the current expressions of anti-refugee
and anti-foreigner violence but we
shouldn't get too panicked by them let's
not forget that the violence of direct
actions aimed against property and
persons has been a contentious presence
in germany going back to the nineteen
and still further in west-germany
through the 80s to the 70s the contexts
for judging that previous violence had
been the ones I just cited how
effectively was that violence opposed by
the left and how resilient were the
given political institutions in the face
of that violence then as now the
political picture was complex and mixed
to return to the now for example an lrb
of September 2016 contained a powerful
piece by Ben Mach cataloguing assaults
on Asylum centers which had been
increasing from 69 in 2013 through 199
in 2014 to over a thousand in 2015 and
even more last year in 2016 there was
also a piece in NY RB by Joshua hammer
around the same time entitled can
Germany cope with the refugees which
balanced discussion of growing
anti-refugee actions with reportage on
official Asylum centers and local
support actions citing the examples of
Hamel and the humanitarian activism of
the Berlin journalist ondrea's talking
what's striking here is the shifting and
variable heterogeneity of political
reactions which can turn very rapidly to
unease to hostility and back again quite
quickly moving out then from these
initial observations I'd like to make
the following quick points first
effective politics requires moving
between the national and supranational
EU levels on the one hand and the
grassroots on the other hand but
unfortunately there's a disastrous dict
disconnect for which Merkel's
grandstanding and maladroit
interventions have been ultimately
responsible it's surely the community
and neighborhood based acts of
solidarity that offer the best hope for
a constructive politics the
demonstration effects of the small acts
of kindness of kindness toward strangers
can never be under
estimated this is patently a matter of
everydayness second historically
speaking treatment of refugees and
asylum seekers cannot be disarticulated
from earlier contexts of immigration and
race these remain vital to weather as
planes and chains of equivalents linking
current reactions with the earlier
crises of the 90s and the labor migrants
II of the 60s and 70s or as the still
unresolved trouble Germans and other
Western Europeans experienced when
thinking about race racialized hostility
against East Asians is distinct from
reactions to Syrians and Afghans just as
the latter are both articulated with and
separable from the broader anti-islamic
fears like the overall politics of
refugees this problem can only be
grasped at the level of the everydayness
to the third point is so obvious as
barely needing to be stated this is
simultaneously a European question
inseparable from the current crisis is
the complete uselessness of the EU in
offering any effective or visionary
leadership at one level this is utter
abdication and irresponsibly
irresponsibility of the Yurok racine but
an effective response to the question of
migrants 'i will never materialize
without some more confident and
persuasive grassroots Europeanism fourth
the current refugee crisis the dismaying
condition of mass migrants C from the
Middle East Central Asia and sub-saharan
Africa is now a permanent state of
emergency this crisis is simply not
going to go away on the one hand
neoliberal globalization has been
shockingly destructive across huge
tracts of the global south where it's
restructured economies impoverished
societies and ruined state
infrastructures and sovereignties on the
other hand by a series incredibly
destructive wars authoritarian states
that were at least economically and
socially functional have now gone
leaving horrendously violent political
wastelands in their place there's now a
complete absence of
affective state sovereignty across a
vast continuous stretch of global
territory running from West Africa
through the Sahel and Northeast Africa
to the Middle East and Central Asia
where ordinary citizens see no choice
but to leave that via the effects of
continuing neoliberal impoverishment
wars and violence and drought famine and
climate change will only continue to get
worse if the early 21st century social
paradigm of gated 'no sand the mentality
of a fortress Europe successfully
established their dominance the
possibilities of producing a more
democratic internationalism will be gone
this is the political field of
right-wing contention to the present of
the present for which contemporary
understandings of race functions so
patently as a primary ordering principle
framed by the far rights political
imaginary of noxious immigrants and
unwelcome foreigners were racialized
versions of social entitlements and
cultural belonging crudely to limit the
terms of citizenship and the grounds for
legitimate political claims in the
widest landscape of racist violence and
anti-foreigner enmities moreover the
high-speed of efficacy of the new media
technology technologies enables an event
in one place to be carried immediately
to perceptions in another so that the
high impact visibility of an election
campaign and the spectacle of an
assassination or a cartoon scandal can
become sutured to the everydayness of
insults and abuse and neighborhoods in
the subways and on the streets we know
from the Eurobarometer and other survey
data that since the 1980s Western
European attitudes have grown
consistently averse to foreigners
especially but not only those from
outside the EU by 1997 two-thirds of all
Europeans described themselves as being
in some degree racist in its noisy
vociferous nests the very presence of an
anti-immigrant
movement eventually realigns the overall
climate of public policy apparently
unstoppably towards its own ground in
the three decades decades separating in
at Powell's 1968 speech from the public
stigmatizing of a silenced speaker
asylum seekers in the 1990s for instance
the boundaries in Britain of acceptable
public discourse on matters of
nationality citizenship and immigration
lastingly shifted in 2005 likewise the
French National Human Rights Commission
found that 55% of French people thought
there were too many foreigners in the
country and one in three described
themselves as racist a rise of 8 percent
from the previous year the next year 51
percent in la Figaro's survey felt
foreigners who did not love France
should get out a long-standing lepen
slogan that became paraphrased by
Nicolas Sarkozy in his 2007 presidential
campaign burying the memory of the
United LaVon lepen front of 2002 race
talk once confined to the margins had
found its way to the center this
suggests a troubling continuity with the
interwar years namely through various
equivalents of the integral nationalism
far-right advocacy has increased
increasingly regrouped around the
programmatic defense of the
distinctiveness of national culture and
it's threatened integrity and the
language deployed by right-wing populist
sculptural identity is now key to how
the alienness of immigrants can be
publicly rationalized such intruders are
people who share neither and national
heritage nor European civilization quote
unquote as historically transmitted who
do not belong who are foreign to the way
we live who lack our cultural and moral
values this emergent ideology of races
choose older arguments from biological
inferiority in favor of a new stress on
that quote exalts the absolute
irreducible difference of the self and
the incommensurability of different
cultural identities the nation's
cultural identity then becomes the
endangered possession whose integrity
needs to be preserved and if necessary
if necessary bitterly defended its key
reference become heritage tradition
collective memory geography and an
elaborate representational report report
hua of differences in culture rather
than blood or even race per se country
by country this new culture alized
racism is blurring the boundaries
between previously I syllable groupings
of the far-right and mainstream
conservatism that remain strongly
oriented around collectively
memorialized and ritually celebrated
cultural patriotism based on national
heritage here Europe signifies in
complex ways since the shelving of
social Europe and the more generous
possibilities attributed at the time to
1992 the EU has ceased for any
foreseeable future to be a feasible
project of manageable socio-political
and cultural integration careening
instead towards a narrowly understood
market defined geopolitical drive for
the purpose of purposes of competitive
globalization the resulting gigantis ism
of the e use current process of
enlargement exacerbates the cultural
izing of racism in a doubled way it
Stokes the country based anxieties
already clustering around the
territories of a vulnerable national
identity it then translates those
resentments onto the meta European Plain
of the defense of besieged
civilizational values this potent
dialectic of simultaneously maintaining
national and European boundaries of
defending the nation from inside the
larger battlements of a fortress Europe
brings together multiple fields of
antagonism drawn with distressing
predictability against Muslims whether
those Muslims are already inside Europe
situated around its borders or perceived
to be on their way the Islamic
Providence and affiliations of migrant
minorities during the earlier period of
the 1960's and 1970's lacked the same
kind of salience then in the 1980s
multiple sites of conflict coalesced
willy-nilly towards a primary
contradiction everyday racism against
Pakistanis and Bangladeshis in Britain
it's analogs in the bad news of France
discrimination against Turks in West
Germany and Austria against Moroccans
and Turks in the Low Countries campaigns
against Muslims in Bulgaria the dissent
toward violence in Bosnia and Kosovo war
between Armenians and his Aires over the
Garnica Bock Karabakh in the 1990s these
hostilities exploded into sustained
crisis further articulated with a range
of conflicts on the wider global stage
but the political logics of anti Islamic
concentration we're still unevenly
apparent the main consequence of 9/11
has been exactly this a further
disastrous radicalizing of all of the
above in ways that simultaneously
concentrate the represent
representational energy against Islam in
many of the most dangerously violent of
the ensuing controversies from Salman
Rushdie rusty to gear builders a
disturbing elision occurs the intricate
dilemmas of how best to preserve
pluralism tolerance and civil liberties
or of how to secure the values of
individual emancipation and the freedoms
of conscience and speech become
translated discursive Lee into emblems
of Death Note national identity and the
broader humanistic heritage of European
civilization these are values we
herewith authoritative regularity which
Islam does not share at timbale bar
describes this slide
logic very well quote from foreigners to
aliens meaning second-class residents
who are deemed to be of a different kind
from protection to discrimination and
from cultural difference to racial
stigmatization within this global field
of post 9/11 antagonisms many
commentators have crudely aligned this
elaborated system of differences with a
differential capacity for democracy
quote Islam and democracy are fully
incompatible they will never be
compatible not today and not in a
million years inevitably demagogy then
fills much of the resulting political
space amid this creeping radicalization
of the right it remains vital to hold on
to a certain key distinction the
importance of separating the self-styled
and overtly neo-fascist groups from the
wider field of right-wing
contentiousness currently concentrating
around migrants see the refugee crisis
fear of foreigners and a generalized
hostility to Islam self-styled
neo-fascist groups and parties do
definitely exist usually on a relative
small scale basis country by country
whether by lines of indigenous descent
from the 1940s and overt nostalgia for
Nazism or from more vicarious forms of
attachment to Nazism or Italian fascism
but still more worrying is the broader
swell of far-right militancy for which
the contemporary language of race for
focused on cultural belonging social
entitlements angry and tolerance of
others and a narrowly conceived idea of
skin and Birth based citizenship has
become the main mobilizing idea the most
disquieting aspect of the present across
Europe as a whole is the convergence of
these two phenomena the ideologically
self-conscious fascist formations on the
one hand and a much broader right-wing
populism centered around ideas of race
on the other proceeding from the
authoritarian grounds ground of the
politics of law and order the resulting
coalition potentially integrate
it's elements of the more traditionalist
conservative sector too while gathering
up the discontents of mini petty
bourgeois and working-class voters
who've been damaged by austerity and the
societal dislocations resulting from
capitalist restructuring and long-range
economic change yet a further ingredient
is supplied by the demonstrable
sympathies inside the police and state
security apparatuses without a
determined self conscious and
imaginative political response to all
this from the left the dangers of an
ever broadening right wing coalescence
of this kind that's capable of shifting
the basic terms of political discourse
decisively to the right become trouble
only troublingly real thank you well
thank you to all three of our speakers
and to Steve for his very convincing
imitation
[Music]